Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. So even though we face the difficulties of today and tomorrow, I still have a dream. It is a dream deeply one day this nation will rise up and live out the true meaning of its creed. We hold these truths to be self-evident that all men are created equal. I have a dream that one day on the red hills of Georgia, the sons of former slaves and the sons of former slave owners will be able to sit down together at the table of brotherhood. I have a dream that one day even the state of Mississippi, a state sweltering with the heat of injustice, sweltering with the heat of oppression, will be transformed into an oasis of freedom and
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。因此，尽管我们面对今天和明天的困难，我仍然有一个梦想。这个梦想深深扎根于美国梦之中，我梦想有一天这个国家会站立起来，真正实现其信条的真谛：我们认为这些真理是不言而喻的，即人人生而平等。我梦想有一天，在佐治亚州的红山上，昔日奴隶的儿子和昔日奴隶主的儿子将能够坐在一起，共叙兄弟情谊。我梦想有一天，甚至连密西西比州，这个正被不公正的热浪所煎熬、被压迫的热浪所煎熬的州，也会被改造成一个自由和
justice. Because I have a dream that my four little children will one day live in a nation where they will not be judged by the colour of their skin but by the content of their character. I have a dream today. That was the Reverend Martin Luther King speaking from the steps of the Lincoln Memorial on the 28th of August, 1963, to a vast
正义的绿洲。因为我有一个梦想，我的四个小孩子有一天将生活在一个国家，在那里，他们不会因为肤色而被评判，而是因为品格的优劣而被评判。我今天有一个梦想。以上是马丁·路德·金牧师于1963年8月28日在林肯纪念堂台阶上发表的演讲，面对着一个庞大的
audience of almost perhaps it's been estimated a quarter of a million people who had joined a great march on Washington to demand civil rights for black people in America. And Dominic, we're just down from the Lincoln Memorial. We've just been up to visit the very spot on the steps where Martin Luther King gave that speech. So if you hear people walking by, if you hear dogs, noise of wind, planes, whatever, that's why. We're on location. And the theme of today is that speech, probably one of the most famous speeches in American history. And one of the most famous speeches, certainly in the 20th century? I think so, absolutely. So it's often voted, certainly in the 20th century i think so absolutely so it's often voted certainly in polls in america will vote at the greatest speech of all time i think it's one of the few
听众群体，据估计大约有二十五万人参加了这场伟大的华盛顿大游行，要求美国黑人享有公民权利。多米尼克，我们现在就在林肯纪念堂下方。我们刚刚参观了马丁·路德·金发表那次演讲的台阶原址。所以如果你听到有人走过，听到狗叫、风声、飞机声或其他什么声音，那就是原因所在。我们在现场录制。今天的主题就是那次演讲，它可能是美国历史上最著名的演讲之一。而且肯定是20世纪最著名的演讲之一吧？我想绝对是。它经常被评选，当然是在20世纪，我想绝对是，所以它经常在美国的民意调查中被评为史上最伟大的演讲，我认为它是少数几个
speeches that has genuinely global cachet yeah because it has a resonance far beyond america oh yeah you can see it it's written on there are bits of it written in on walls on the west bank uh at tiananmen square in 1989 protesters held up placards with the words, I have a dream. So yeah, absolutely. It has this resonance. And also where we are, Tom, I mean, people come to the Lincoln Memorial and come to the spot where King gave his speech. So they're visiting not just Lincoln, but they're visiting King. And King's Memorial is very close to where we're sitting now. And for people in America, for a lot of people, this is a place of pilgrimage. These are two great saints.
真正具有全球影响力的演讲之一。是的，因为它在美国之外也有着深远的回响。哦，是的，你可以看到，它的片段被写在西岸的墙上；1989年在天安门广场，抗议者举着写有“我有一个梦想”字样的标语牌。所以，是的，绝对如此。它有着这种共鸣。而且汤姆，我们现在所处的位置，人们来到林肯纪念堂，来到金发表演讲的地方。所以他们不仅是在瞻仰林肯，也是在瞻仰金。金的纪念碑离我们现在坐的地方非常近。对于美国人来说，对于很多人来说，这是一个朝圣之地。这两位都是伟大的圣人。
Okay. So you've given me an opening there. Right. You often criticize me for shoehorning sacral Christian references in. Yeah. But Martin Luther King is a reverend. And I think it's really important to understanding the tone, the timbre, the resonance of the speech to recognize that King is a preacher. Yes, absolutely. So what we're going to do today is we're going to come to the speech, and we're going to come to the great drama of King stepping up to the podium to address this
好吧。你给了我一个开场白。没错。你经常批评我硬塞入神圣的基督教引用。是的，但马丁·路德·金是一位牧师。我认为要理解这次演讲的基调、音色和共鸣，认识到金是一位传道人是非常重要的。是的，绝对如此。所以我们今天要讲的是这次演讲，我们要讲到金走上讲台向这个
audience. By the way, not just the quarter of a million people around him, but millions of Americans watching on television. Yeah, because it's on network news, isn't it? And they switch to broadcast it live. To cover that part of the speech. Exactly right. Exactly right. So we'll talk about the speech itself a little bit later. But maybe first, Tom, what we should do is give a bit of context. Because this is not just a story about one bit of rhetoric. It's a story about a man and a moment. And it's a story about a point in American history that actually, we haven't really covered in the rest of history. Well, we talked about the American Civil War, didn't we?
听众群体发表讲话的伟大戏剧性时刻。顺便说一下，不仅是周围的二十五万人，还有数百万通过电视观看的美国人。是的，因为那是电视新闻直播，对吧？他们切换到现场直播。为了报道演讲的那一部分。完全正确。完全正确。所以我们稍后再谈演讲本身。但汤姆，也许我们首先应该提供一些背景。因为这不仅仅是一个关于一段修辞的故事。这是一个关于一个人和一个时刻的故事。这是一个关于美国历史上一个我们实际上在《历史的余味》中还没有真正涉及的点的故事。嗯，我们谈论过美国内战，不是吗？
And then we talked about the way in which segregation continued despite the victory of the Union and the abolition of slavery. Exactly. Into the 20th century and still in the 50s. Oh, yes. And into the 60s, there is segregation in many states, particularly across the South, between black and white American citizens. Yeah, absolutely.
然后我们谈论了尽管北方联邦取得了胜利并废除了奴隶制，但种族隔离制度依然存在的方式。完全正确。一直持续到20世纪，甚至在50年代。哦，是的。一直到60年代，许多州，特别是在南方，黑人和白人美国公民之间仍然存在种族隔离。是的，绝对如此。
So what were called the Jim Crow laws that were brought in after the failure of Reconstruction at the end of the American Civil War. So these were, I mean, to our non-American listeners who are not familiar with this, this would be the American equivalent of a kind of apartheid. So, you know, black people can't sit in the same part of the bus. They can't sit at lunch counters. They can't go to the same schools. They can't go to universities. All of these kinds of things. All of these in the same part of the bus they can't sit at lunch counters they can't go to the same schools they can't go to universities all of these kinds of things or at least the same universities we'll give a bit of context on this i know it's a massive subject it's sometimes thought
这就是美国内战结束后重建失败后引入的所谓“吉姆·克劳法”。所以，对于那些不熟悉这一点的非美国听众来说，这相当于美国版的种族隔离制度。所以，你知道，黑人不能坐在公交车的同一区域。他们不能坐在午餐柜台前。他们不能去同一所学校。他们不能上同一所大学。所有这些事情。所有这些在公交车的同一区域，他们不能坐在午餐柜台前，他们不能去同一所学校，他们不能去同一所大学，所有这些事情，或者至少不能去同一所大学。我们会对此提供一些背景，我知道这是一个宏大的主题，有时人们认为
the civil rights movement just comes out of nowhere that's not right there had always been civil rights campaigners from the 1890s onwards there had always been people pushing back trying to push back of course it's very difficult because i mean the southern governments have almost untrammeled power there is violence there's constant violence there is lynching so kukwax clan burning crosses and and all that it's not just the clan though it's also you know the police yeah the the entire infrastructure of oppression but from the second world war something obviously changes and that's partly because of the service of African Americans in the war. There's also a landmark Supreme Court decision in 1954. Listeners who are familiar with this story will know exactly what I'm talking about. It's called Brown versus the Board of Education. And this begins to desegregate schools. So it basically says segregated schools, separate but equal as they were called are not right they're unconstitutional they are wrong um but but Dominic something else that changes presumably is television and radio and mass media yeah because you were talking about how difficult it is for the campaign
民权运动是凭空出现的，那是不对的。从1890年代开始就一直有民权活动家，一直有人在反抗，试图推翻它。当然这非常困难，因为南方政府拥有几乎不受限制的权力。那里有暴力，有持续的暴力，有私刑，有三K党焚烧十字架等等。但这不仅仅是三K党，还有警察，是的，整个压迫的基础设施。但从第二次世界大战开始，情况显然发生了变化，这部分是因为非裔美国人在战争中的服役。1954年还有一个具有里程碑意义的最高法院裁决。熟悉这个故事的听众会确切地知道我在说什么。它被称为“布朗诉教育委员会案”。这开始了学校的去种族隔离化。所以它基本上说，种族隔离的学校，即所谓的“隔离但平等”是不对的，它们违宪，它们是错误的。嗯，但是多米尼克，还有什么发生了变化呢？大概是电视、广播和大众媒体吧。是的，因为你刚才谈到运动是多么困难
to kind of take wing but if it's being amplified on television yeah then presumably opportunities for for mass movements to grab attention are massively enhanced. That's absolutely right. And there's one other outside aspect to this, which is, of course, the Cold War. This is very bad publicity for the United States when it's claiming to stand for freedom against Soviet communism. Democracy and liberty. You have a series of incidents which you won't, you know,
才能起飞，但如果它在电视上被放大，那么大众运动吸引注意力的机会就会大大增强。完全正确。而且还有一个外部因素，当然就是冷战。当美国声称代表自由对抗苏联共产主义时，这对美国来说是非常糟糕的宣传。民主和自由。你有一系列事件，顺便说一下，每一个都值得单独做一期播客。我相信我们最终会把它们都讲一遍。最著名的一个当然是罗莎·帕克斯和1955年蒙哥马利公交车抵制运动的故事。所以罗莎·帕克斯拒绝接受她在公交车上的二等公民地位，我们的许多听众，不仅仅是美国人，都会熟悉那个故事。蒙哥马利公交车抵制运动是第一次真正看到马丁·路德·金博士作为一个全国性人物出现的时刻。金其实个子很矮，但他身上有一种东西，即使在那个时候，正如你所说，他是一位基督徒，他是一位牧师，他是一位浸信会传道人，他带着这种巨大的道德
they're all worthy of podcasts in themselves, by the way. I'm sure we'll do them all eventually. The most famous one is, of course, the storyosa parks and the montgomery bus boycott in 1955 so rosa parks who refuses to accept her second class status on the bus lots of our listeners not just americans will be familiar with that story the montgomery bus boycott is the first moment where you really see the emergence of this this character dr martin luther king jr as a as a national figure he's quite a short man king actually um but he has there's something about him even at that point as you said he's a christian he's a clergyman he's a baptist preacher and he carries this immense moral
权威。当他说话时，带着圣经的韵律。是的，绝对如此。他以先知的声音说话。我的意思是，字面意义上的先知之声。他引用了希伯来先知的意象。而且他一直在演讲。所以1963年，预先说明一下，他几乎每天都发表演讲。我想在365天的一年里大约有350场演讲。所以他在这方面非常出色。我们将谈谈他是如何精心设计演讲以吸引
authority when he speaks it's with the cadences of the Bible. Yes, absolutely. He speaks with a prophetic voice. I mean, literally a prophetic voice. He is invoking images from the Hebrew prophets. And he's speaking all the time. So in 1963, just to anticipate, he gives a speech practically every single day. I think something like 350 speeches in a 365-day year. So he's brilliant at it. And we'll come on to how he crafts his speeches to appeal
不同类型的听众的。顺便说一下，做得非常出色。但回到背景，民权运动的势头在1950年代末、1960年代初加速。你有一系列事件，50年代末阿肯色州小石城的强制学校整合，1960年北卡罗来纳州开始的静坐浪潮，所谓的“自由乘车者”，也就是一群人，他们会在1961年乘坐州际巴士试图废除公交车上的种族隔离。1962年一个非常著名的故事，一个叫詹姆斯·梅雷迪思的学生，他成为了
to different kinds of audiences. Absolutely brilliantly done, by the way. But to go back to the context, the momentum of civil rights accelerates in the late 1950s, early 1960s. You have a whole series of incidents, the forced integration of schools in Little Rock, Arkansas at the end of the 50s, wave of sit-ins starting in North Carolina in 1960, the so-called freedom riders, so people who ride, they are a group, they will ride interstate buses in 1961 to try and desegregate the buses. A very famous story in 1962, a student called James Meredith, who became
密西西比大学的第一位黑人学生。但1963年发生了一些变化。所以这就是关键的一年。所以有一种真正的、势头的加剧。所以有几件事。非常著名的是阿拉巴马大学的去种族隔离。现在，阿拉巴马州州长乔治·华莱士，很多听众都听过他的名字，他成为了种族隔离的捍卫者。
the first black student at the University of Mississippi. But something changes in 1963. So this is the year. So there's a real, it's a kind of ratcheting up of the momentum. So there are a couple of things. Very famously, the desegregation of the University of Alabama. Now, the governor of Alabama, Governor George Wallace, lots of listeners will have heard his name, he becomes the champion of segregation.
他真的站在了校门口，汤姆，他说，我向暴政投下挑战书，挺身对抗联邦政府，我们现在支持种族隔离，明天支持种族隔离，永远支持种族隔离。因为这是理解的关键，不是吗？双方都认为自己是正确的。而我们，在21世纪，我们可以清楚地看到马丁·路德·金和民权运动在哪些方面是正确的。
And he literally stands, Tom, in the schoolhouse door, and he says, I fling down the gauntlet in the face of tyranny, standing up to the federal government, and we stand for segregation now, segregation tomorrow, segregation forever. Because that's the important thing to understand, isn't it? That both sides think that they're right. And we, in the 21st century, we can clearly see the ways in which Martin Luther King and the civil rights movement are right.
但重要的是要理解，对于大量的白人美国人来说，他们认为自己是正确的。而且他们是在反对暴政和压迫。联邦政府的暴政。完全正确。然后他们说他们支持“州权”。绝对，这正是他们所说的。在1963年的春天和夏天，也就是通往这一时刻的几个月里，有一种明确的紧张局势加剧的感觉，马丁·路德·金经常出现在新闻中。所以1963年，在1963年的春天，像《纽约时报》这样的报纸刊登的关于民权的报道比
But it is important to understand that for large numbers of white Americans, they think they're in the right. And that they're campaigning against tyranny and oppression. The tyranny of the federal government. That's exactly right. Then they say they stand for states' rights. Absolutely, that's exactly what they say and there was a definite sense in the spring and summer of 1963 so in the months that lead up to this moment of tension rising and martin luther king has been in the news a lot so in 1963 in the spring of 1963 a newspaper like the new york times are running more stories about civil rights than they
过去几年的总和还要多。这是一个非凡显著性的标志。你提到了电视，有一个电视转播的时刻，不仅传遍了美国家庭，而且传遍了全世界，这就是金去了阿拉巴马州的伯明翰，或者我们会说伯明翰，是的，我们会，但他们会说伯明翰。所以他去了伯明翰，这是一个臭名昭著的暴力种族隔离主义地方，它被称为“炸弹之城”（Bombingham），因为太多的民权活动家受到攻击，是的，那里有太多针对民权领袖家园的炸弹袭击。他去了那里，领导了这些抗议活动，而伯明翰的当局，最著名的是这位警察局长，他简直是荒谬的化身，他叫尤金·“公牛”·康纳，对吧，“公牛”康纳，他放出警犬去对付抗议者。
had done in the in the previous years put together it's a sign of the extraordinary salience that this has you mentioned television there's this one televised moment that goes not just around american households but around the world and this is king goes to birmingham alabama or we would say birmingham yes we would but they would say birmingham so he goes to birmingham which is a notoriously violent segregationist place it's been nicknamed bombingham because so many civil rights activists are being attacked yeah have been there have been so many bomb attacks on civil rights leaders homes and he goes there and he leads these protests and the authorities in birmingham most famously this police chief who beyond parody he's called eugene bull connor right bull connor sets dogs on the protesters
而抗议者是孩子，不是吗？嗯，起初不是。金在某个时候被关进监狱，他写了这封著名的……嗯，因为他很有名，从伯明翰监狱发出的信。从伯明翰监狱。这封从伯明翰监狱发出的信，他在信中说，他把它写在卫生纸上，写在他牢房里报纸的边缘。他谈到了“当下的紧迫性”。他说，我们等待得太久了。
and the protesters are children aren't they well not at first king is jailed at one point and he writes this famous... Well, because he's famous, the letter from Birmingham Jail. From Birmingham Jail. This letter from Birmingham Jail where he says, he writes it on toilet paper, and he writes it at the margins of a newspaper in his cell. And he talks about the fierce urgency of now. And he says, we have waited too long.
我们忍耐得太久了。就是现在。然后当他出来时，他做了一件事，他加倍努力，他招募了孩子，黑人学童，他把他们放进抗议活动中，放在前线。当然，这让你提到了电视，这造就了非凡的电视画面，他们是那些被警犬、高压水枪、当局的全部力量所针对的人，那种愤怒正在发泄。是的。所以你刚才说肯尼迪政府的人对这些场景如何不利于美国展示
We have been patient too long. This is the moment. And then when he comes out, he does this thing where he doubles down and he enlists children black school children he puts them in in the protest puts them in the front line and of course that makes you mentioned telly that makes for extraordinary television that they are the people on whom the dogs the water cannons the full force of the authorities, that wrath is being vented. Yes. And so you were saying about how people in the Kennedy administration are kind of very sensitive to the way in which these kind of scenes are not conducive to America presenting
自己作为自由堡垒的方式非常敏感。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，这有点像你在种族隔离的南非看到的东西。哦，可怕的场景。对肯尼迪来说是一个巨大的尴尬。所以约翰·F·肯尼迪，他从1961年1月上任以来。但他真正的困境是他的选举联盟包括南方白人。是的，当然。他走在一条非常细的线上。实际上，他和他的兄弟罗伯特，也就是负责法律和秩序的司法部长罗伯特·肯尼迪，在这一点上说，我希望他们能安静下来，我希望这一切都能消失，为什么
itself as the bulwark of liberty. Yes, absolutely right. I mean, that's kind of like the stuff you're getting in apartheid South Africa. Oh, terrible scenes. A huge embarrassment for Kennedy. So John F. Kennedy, he's been in since January 1961. But the real dilemma for him is that his electoral coalition includes the white South. Yeah, of course. He is treading a very fine line. And actually, he and his brother Robert, so Robert Kennedy is the Attorney General responsible for law and order. And Robert Kennedy is saying at this point, I wish they they would just pipe down i wish this would all go away why
他们不能……他们需要和所有人使用同一个厕所吗？他们需要乘坐同一辆公交车吗？你知道，他们不能只是……因为他们感到沮丧，肯尼迪政府，因为他们能看到，他们能看到这个案件的道德力量，我想虽然他们并不完全理解它，但他们能在智力上看到它，但他们也害怕走得太远而疏远他们的南方白人基础。但有两种白人观点，大概马丁·路德·金正试图招募到他这一边，一种是肯尼迪所代表的那种进步自由主义，但还有一种感觉，不是吗，金
can't they just do they need to go to the toilet in the same toilets as everybody else do they need to ride on the same buses that you know can't they just you know because they're frustrated the kennedy administration because they can see they can see the moral force of the case i think although they don't quite understand it but they can sort of see it intellectually but also they're terrified about going too far and alienating their white southern base but there are two kind of strains of white opinion that presumably martin luther king is trying to um recruit to his side and one is that kind of progressive liberalism that kennedy stands for but there is also, isn't there, a sense that King
正试图羞辱南方白人基督徒。所以那封从伯明翰监狱发出的信，我的意思是，他有这句不可思议的话，说耶稣是爱的极端分子。他把自己比作被监禁的圣保罗。有一种想法是，如果他能唤醒他真正相信的那种精神冲动，即圣灵降临并激励他，如果他能让白人基督徒分享那种精神冲动，那么谁知道会发生什么呢？他真的，我的意思是，他绝对相信这一点，他是一个非常虔诚的人，汤姆，我的意思是，这不仅仅是门面功夫，他不是白白当浸信会传道人的，他是浸信会传道人的儿子。我想他是第三代浸信会传道人。所以他所说的一切都注入了圣经的韵律。
is trying to shame white Southern Christians. So that letter from Birmingham Jail, I mean, he has this incredible phrase that Jesus was an extremist for love. And he compares himself to St. Paul being jailed. And there is this idea that if only he can awaken a sense of the spirit rush that he literally believes in that the spirit descends and animates him and he can get white christians to share in that spirit rush then who knows what might happen right and he really i mean he he absolutely believes this it's a very religious man tom i mean this isn't window dressing i mean he he's a he's not a baptist preacher for nothing and he's the son of a Baptist preacher. I think he's the third generation of Baptist preachers. So everything that he says is infused with the cadences of the Bible.
是的。所以他所阐述的基督教思想是，你不能通过做不公正的事情来获得正义。对吧。所以非暴力等等。我们必须升华到用灵魂的力量去应对物理力量的崇高境界。是的，但民权运动中有些人并不一定同意这一点。完全正确。所以有另一个选民群体，还有另一个方面。金不仅仅是一位传道人，他现在是一位政治家。这听起来可能很奇怪，因为他显然从未当选过政治职位，但他是一位政治行动者，政治代理人，他有一个他不能失去的黑人选民群体。整个1963年，随着压力上升，这些暴力场景在电视上播出，黑人社区里有人在说，受够了。是的，所以马尔科姆·X，所以马尔科姆·X，是的，他不是基督徒，他皈依了伊斯兰教。没错。而伊斯兰教提供了一种在获得正义方面稍微强硬一点的方法。他的吸引力稍微不同。他的大本营不同。它在北方的大城市。比如纽约，芝加哥，诸如此类的地方。
Yeah. And so the Christian idea that he is articulating is that you don't obtain justice by doing unjust things. Right. So nonviolence and so on. We must rise to the majestic heights of meeting physical force with soul force yeah but there are people in the civil rights movement who don't necessarily agree with that exactly so there's another constituency and there's another aspect king king is not just a preacher he's a politician now that may sound odd because he's obviously never elected to political office but he's a political actor political agent and he has a black constituency that he cannot afford to lose and throughout 1963 as the pressure is rising and these violent scenes are shown on television there are people in the
他的态度非常不同。他说，我支持暴力。如果非暴力意味着我们为了避免暴力而继续推迟美国黑人问题的解决方案，对吧？而且确实有很多人，随着1963年夏天的进展，有人在对金说，你太慢了，你太……你太胆小了，我们应该……你知道，你谈论“当下的紧迫性”，好吧，如果你是认真的，我们就必须做点什么。对吧？所以马丁·路德·金实际上走在一条非常细的线上，不是吗？因为一方面，他有黑人活动家，他们可能被诱惑去支持马尔科姆·X的论点，
black community who are saying enough of this yeah so malcolm x so malcolm x yeah who is not a christian has converted to Islam. Correct. And Islam offers perhaps a slightly more muscular approach to obtaining justice. And his appeal is slightly different. His heartland is different. It's in the big cities of the North. So New York, for example, Chicago, places like that.
即非暴力是一个失败的策略；而另一方面，马丁·路德·金需要向白人自由派展示，是的，试图把他们也招募到事业中来。自由派和白人温和派，我会这么说。所以那些不是特别政治化的人，基本上没有真正考虑过这个问题，只想让问题消失的人。他必须动员他们的愤怒，他必须让他们感到愤怒，他必须让他们通过他的眼睛看世界。正确，完全正确。所以这就是背景，现在让我们谈谈平台，因为是什么给了他机会？这不是金的想法去举行这次游行。从来没有过这样的游行。所以现在我们生活在一个巨大的、成千上万的人
And his attitude is very different. He says, I am for violence. If nonviolence means we continue postponing a solution to the american black man's problem just to avoid violence right and there are a lot of people who actually as 1963 as the summer progresses there are people who are saying to king you're too slow you're too you're too kind of lily-livered we should you know that you talk about the fierce urgency of now well if you mean it we have to do something right so martin luther king is actually treading quite a fine line isn't he because on the one hand he has black activists who may be tempted to side with malcolm x's arguments
涌向华盛顿的想法相当普遍的世界里。所以它可能是茶党，可能是特朗普支持者，可能是民权活动家，可能是“黑人的命也是命”，可能是……它在1963年之前并没有真正发生过。这个想法来自老一代的民权领袖。所以负责这件事的人是这个叫A·菲利普·伦道夫的人。现在，菲利普·伦道夫于1889年出生在佛罗里达州，他是一位工会领袖，他是一位黑人，他组织了“卧铺车厢搬运工兄弟会”。我的意思是，那是一个伟大的名字。那是一个伟大的名字。我的意思是，它是一张专辑，它是一个团体的绝佳名字。是的，不是吗？前卫摇滚。约翰·皮尔会喜欢的。约翰·皮尔会喜欢那个的。完全正确。所以……而且他实际上是一个相当怀旧的人物，因为他穿着这些
that that non-violence is a busted flush and on the other hand martin luther king needs to appear to white liberals yes um to try and recruit them to the cause as well liberals and white moderates i would say so people who are not particularly political so people who basically haven't really thought about it want the problem to go away he has to mobilize their outrage he has to get them outraged he has to get them to see the world through his eyes correct exactly exactly right so that's the context and now let's talk a little bit about the platform because what gives him the opportunity it's not king's idea to have this march there has never been a march like it so now we live in a world where the idea of huge hundreds of thousands of people
深色羊毛三件套西装。他是一个非常……在南方，他是一个极其庄重的人。天哪，他一定出了很多汗，对吧？所以他第一次提出华盛顿游行的想法是在1941年。当时美国即将进入第二次世界大战，他希望游行是关于军队中的种族隔离，当时军队是隔离的，以及国防工业。他被富兰克林·D·罗斯福说服放弃了，罗斯福说，你知道，在战争中心，这分裂性太强，不是个好主意。罗斯福作为一种交换条件，曾说，我会废除战争工业中的种族隔离。不是军队，杜鲁门做了那个。所以罗斯福，是的，他们达成了一项协议，游行从未发生。但到了1963年，菲利普·伦道夫想再试一次。他现在74岁了。他认为这是最后一次
descending on washington is quite common so it might be the tea party it might be trumpists it might be civil rights campaigners it might be black lives matter it might be it hasn't really happened before in 1963 and the idea comes from an older generation of civil rights leaders so the guy who's responsible for it's this guy called a philip randolph now philip randolph was born in florida in 1889 and he was a union leader he was a black man he organized the brotherhood of sleeping car porters i mean that's a great name it's a great name i mean it's an album it's a brilliant name for a group yeah isn't it progressive rock yeah progressive john peel would have loved it john peel would have loved that exactly so um and he's actually quite a nostalgic figure because he wears these
机会让他实现他的梦想。他梦想……我的意思是，这是他一生的梦想。他有一个梦想。他确实有一个梦想，汤姆。在他身边的是一个比他年轻一点的人，50多岁，叫贝亚德·拉斯汀。他是一个迷人的人物。他是一个非凡的……所以他非常高，他非常古怪，他有一头乱蓬蓬的头发，他是一个贵格会教徒，他是一个迷人的人。就像理查德·尼克松。但他和理查德·尼克松非常不同。
dark wool three-piece suits he's a very in the south he's an immensely dignified man god he must be sweated a lot right so he had first come up with the idea of the march on washington in 1941 so as america is about to enter the second world war and he wanted the march to be about segregation in the military which was then segregated and in the defense industry and he was persuaded out of it by franklin d ro Roosevelt, who said, you know, not a good idea with a centering the war, divisive. And Roosevelt had, as a sort of quid pro quo, had said, I will desegregate war industries. Not the military, Truman did that. So Roosevelt, yeah, they did a deal and the march never happened. But by 1963, Philip Randolph wants to have another go. He's now 74. And he thinks this is one lastandolph wants to have another go he's now 74 and he thinks this
在其他方面。在其他方面。他是一个和平主义者。他是一个共产主义者。而且他也是一个公开的同性恋者，在那个时代这非常罕见。所以1953年，他实际上在帕萨迪纳被捕，并被指控因在车后座与两名男子发生性关系而犯有淫秽流浪罪，他被送进监狱60天。现在，正如你所知，汤姆，许多民权领袖都是虔诚的基督徒，对贝亚德·拉斯汀感到非常不舒服，但
is one last chance for him to have his dream he dreams i mean this is his lifelong dream he has a dream he does have a dream tom and by his side is a man who is a bit younger than him who's in his 50s called bayard rustin he's a fascinating figure he's an extraordinary so he's incredibly tall he's very eccentric he has a sort of mop of hair he's a quaker he's a fascinating man. So he's incredibly tall. He's very eccentric. He has a sort of mop of hair. He's a Quaker. He's a fascinating man. Like Richard Nixon. But he's very unlike Richard Nixon.
他是一位出色的组织者，并且绝对忠诚于这项事业。但我认为这也很有趣，因为他似乎是基督教和自由派民权发展之间的一个交叉点。但他也是一个迷人的人物，因为他是与共产主义者的联系。我的意思是，他是一个共产主义者。实际上，虽然承认这一点让一些民权领袖感到尴尬，但共产主义者在民权运动中非常活跃，因为当然，共产党是一个公开的反种族主义政党。而且有些人，共产主义者在民权运动中非常活跃，因为当然，共产党是一个公开的反种族主义政党。而且有一些美国共产主义者，他们非常理想主义，并且绝对忠诚于平等和兄弟情谊以及所有这些东西的事业。所以这是一个联盟。这是一个联盟。一个联合阵线。
In other ways. In other ways. He's a pacifist. He is a communist. And he is also openly gay at a time when that is very unusual. So in 1953, he'd actually been arrested in Pasadena and charged with lewd vagrancy for having sex with two men in the back of his car and he'd been sent to jail for 60 days now as you will know tom a lot of the civil rights leaders are intensely christian and are very uncomfortable with bayard rustin but
所以他们基本上把这个想法推销给了其他民权领袖，推销给了来自全国城市联盟、全国有色人种协进会（NAACP）、种族平等大会、学生非暴力协调委员会（SNCC）的人，SNCC非常活跃。它叫SNCC。
he's a brilliant organizer and absolutely devoted to the cause but i think also it's fascinating because he seems as a kind of intersection point between the the christian and the liberal right development of civil rights but he's also a fascinating figure because he's a link to the communist i mean he's a communist and actually although it embarrasses some of the civil rights leaders to admit it the communists are very active in civil rights campaigns because of course the communist party is an avaredly anti-racist party and there are people who, the communists are very active in civil rights campaigns because, of course, the Communist Party is an avaredly anti-racist party. And there are people who are American communists who are very idealistic and are absolutely devoted to the cause of equality and brotherhood and all this sort of stuff. So it's an alliance. It's an alliance. A coalition.
那是一个伟大的名字。而且它在南方非常活跃，在南方做了很多竞选活动。起初，实际上，所有其他民权领袖都说，我不知道，他们不是特别热情。但金对它很热心，不是吗？
So they basically pitch the idea to the other civil rights leaders, to the people from the National Urban League, from the NAACP, the National Association for the Advancement of Coloured People, from the Congress of Racial Equality, from the Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee, which is called SNCC, which is very active. It's called SNCC.
因为这是亚伯拉罕·林肯发表《解放黑人奴隶宣言》一百周年。是的，我们正坐在他的阴影下。我们目前正坐着。是的。所以他能看到那种共鸣。因为同样，正如他试图让白人基督徒以基督教术语认识到他所说的话的正义性一样，
That's a great name. And it's very active in the South, doing a lot of the campaigning in the South. And at first, actually, all the other civil rights leaders say, I don't know, they're not terribly enthusiastic. But King is keen on it, isn't he?
同样，你知道，在这个周年纪念日，他可以让爱国美国人认识到，他只是在为黑人要求宪法中写明的东西。好吧，你预料得非常出色，汤姆，我必须说，他演讲的伟大主题之一，就是我们要求美国承诺得到兑现。我们要求支票被兑现。
Because it's the centenary of the Emancipation Proclamation given by Abraham Lincoln. Yeah, in whose shadow we are sitting. We're currently sitting. Yeah. And so he can see the kind of resonance of that. Because again, just as he's trying to get white Christians to recognize the justice of what he's saying in Christian terms,
完全正确。而且我认为……我的意思是，人们开玩笑说，基本上……但他起初对此有一点矛盾，但到了仲夏，他基本上已经说服自己，这从一开始就是他的主意。我想你需要那种自信，才能做他所做的事情。所以六月底，他们去见约翰·F·肯尼迪。现在，肯尼迪在伯明翰事件之后，已经致力于民权和民权立法，尽管他知道这会使他在南方白人中极其不受欢迎。我们在这里跳跃了。我们将制作一期关于肯尼迪11月遇刺的播客。当他到达达拉斯时，他焦虑的原因之一是
so also, you know, with this anniversary, he can get patriotic Americans to recognize that he's only asking for black people what is written into the Constitution. Well, you're anticipating brilliantly, Tom, I have to say, one of the great themes of his speech, which is that we're asking for the American promise to be redeemed. We're asking for the check to be cashed.
因为他知道有太多的南方白人因为他与民权的认同而厌恶他。实际上，当他们见到肯尼迪时，肯尼迪仍然有点拖拖拉拉。所以他私下对金说，如果这涉及一大堆共产主义者，我不希望你这样做，你知道这对你非常不利，通过关联这对我也很不利。他们与肯尼迪进行了这次会面，他们对他说，听着，它可能会发生，而且无论如何都会发生，让我们谈谈吧，无论如何我们都要做，如果我们以某种方式与你联合，确保它是和平的，这会更好。他们还对他说，如果你不与我们结盟，你就是把主动权交给了激进分子，你知道，交给了马尔科姆·X，交给了这些人。如果我们站在同一立场上会好得多。但那种未言明的交换条件
That's exactly right and i think i mean people sort of joke and they say basically having but he was a tiny bit ambivalent about it at first but by midsummer he basically has convinced himself that it was his idea all along i guess you need that kind of self-confidence yeah to do what he does so at the end of june they go to see john f kennedy now kennedy in the wake of Birmingham, has committed himself to civil rights and civil rights legislation, even though he knows it will make him exceedingly unpopular in the white South. We're jumping ahead here. We're going to do a podcast about Kennedy's assassination in November. When he arrives in Dallas, one of the reasons he is anxious is
是他们将边缘化他们自己群体、他们自己联盟中更激进的分子。他们那样做了吗？他们确实那样做了。所以他们在七月初在哈莱姆会面。
because he knows there are so many white Southerners who loathe him because of his identification with civil rights and actually when they meet kennedy kennedy is is still dragging his feet a bit so he says to king privately i don't want you to do this if it's involved with a load of communists you know this is very bad for you it's bad for me by association they have this meeting with kennedy and they say to him listen it's probably going to happen and it's going to happen anyway let's talk about it anyway we're going to do it whatever it's better if we do it kind of in association with you if it makes sure it's peaceable and they also say to him if you don't ally with us you're handing the initiative to the radicals you know to malcolm x to these kinds of people it's much better if we're on the same page. But the sort of unspoken quid pro quo
所以是菲利普·伦道夫，组织者，那个卧铺车厢搬运工的家伙，以及其他团体的领袖。他们对他说，贝亚德·拉斯汀，帕萨迪纳淫秽流浪罪先生，是的，他必须被推入阴影中，他不能在前面游行，你必须亲自带头。他说，好吧，只要你们允许我挑选我自己的
is that they will sideline the more radical elements of their own group, their own coalition. And do they do that? They do do that. So they meet in Harlem in early July.
副手，我就做。他们说，好吧，没问题。他说，太好了，我的副手是贝亚德·拉斯汀。所以贝亚德·拉斯汀，他在幕后，他做了所有的计划。实际上，他在这方面非常出色，汤姆，因为我说过没有人计划过这样的游行，他做到了。所有的细节。所以是贝亚德·拉斯汀，他在幕后，他做了所有的计划。实际上，他在这方面非常出色，汤姆，因为我说过没有人计划过这样的游行，他做到了。所有的细节。所以是贝亚德·拉斯汀，他解决了平庸的事情，但它们非常重要。他们需要多少厕所，多少毯子。他是那个，你在笔记中给我的精彩细节，
So it's Philip Randolph, the organizer, the sleeping car porter's chap, and the other leaders of the groups. And they say to him, Bayard Rustin, Mr. Pasadena lewd vagrancy yeah he has to be pushed into the shadows he can't march at the front and you have to spearhead this yourself and he says fine i'll do that as long as you allow me to pick my own
他们建议人们不要在三明治里放蛋黄酱，因为它在阳光下容易变质，会导致腹泻。是的。对细节如此关注。嗯，你必须对这些事情有细节关注，否则它就不会奏效。有趣的是，当然，很多人非常反对这一点，我的意思是白人。
deputy and they say okay fine he says great my deputy is bayard rustin so bayard rustin he's in the background he does all the planning and actually he's brilliant at it tom because i said no one has ever planned a march like this and he does it and all the details so it's bayard Rustin, he's in the background, he does all the planning. And actually, he's brilliant at it, Tom, because I said no one has ever planned a march like this. And he does it. And all the details. So it's Bayard Rustin who works out banal things, but they're really important. How many toilets they need, how many blankets. Is he the one who, the brilliant detail you've given in your notes for me,
所以对于公众来说，这是一个迷人的细节。在公众中，对游行持负面看法的人数是持正面看法人数的两倍。南方白人代表绝对是直言不讳的。所以有一个来自南卡罗来纳州的代表威廉·道恩，他说这让人想起墨索里尼法西斯黑衫军向罗马进军，这让人想起社会主义者希特勒在纽伦堡举办的政府赞助的集会。所以，把你的敌人比作希特勒的整个做法真的开始了。是的，非常多。一位非常著名的、种族隔离主义的参议员斯特罗姆·瑟蒙德，
they advise people not to put mayonnaise in their sandwiches because it spoils easily in the sun and can cause diarrhea. Yeah. Such attention to detail. Well, you have to have attention to detail about these things, because otherwise it won't work. The interesting thing, of course, a lot of people are very much against this, by which I mean white people.
他以320岁的高龄仍然是南卡罗来纳州的参议员。他说，这全是贝亚德·拉斯汀干的。他是一个共产主义者、逃兵和同性恋者。他不是发表了一张他在浴缸里和马丁·路德·金交谈的照片吗？在浴缸里。是的。但是，当局有各种各样的，你知道，应急恐慌措施。实际上非常非凡。
So with the public, this is a fascinating detail. Among the public, twice as many people have an unfavorable view of the march as have a favorable view of it. White Southern representatives are absolutely outspoken so there's a guy from south carolina representative william dawn he says this is reminiscent of the mussolini fascist black shirt march on rome it's reminiscent of the socialist hitler's government sponsored rallies in nuremberg so so the whole compare your enemies to hitler is really kicking in. Yes, very much. A very famous, uh, segregationist Senator Strom Thurmond,
所以这是《卫报》专栏作家加里·杨写的，他写了一本关于“我有一个梦想”演讲和华盛顿游行的精彩书籍。这是来自他的书。他说，华盛顿特区所有择期手术都被取消了，因为他们认为会有太多的暴力，医院里会有太多的人。酒精销售被禁止，法官被告知准备进行通宵的刑事听证会，国会议员告诉他们的女性员工远离城市，因为
who was still Senator from South Carolina at the age of 320. He said, this is all Bayard Rustin's doing. He is a communist, a draft dodger and a homosexual. Didn't he published a photo of him talking to Martin Luther King in the bath? In the bath. Yeah. But, um, the authorities have all kinds of, you know, contingency panic measures. Extraordinary, actually.
会有麻烦，会有暴力，所有这些事情。五角大楼有19,000名士兵，但没有警犬，但没有……让步。因为他们已经了解到……那看起来不太好。在我们接近那一天之前，还有几件小事。第一，没有女性。这是一个非常、非常有趣的……所以没有罗莎·帕克斯。所以没有罗莎·帕克斯。
So this is from the Guardian columnist, Gary Young, wrote a brilliant book about the I Have a Dream speech in the March on Washington. This is from his book. He says, all elective surgeries in Washington, D.C. were cancelled because they thought there would be so much violence, there'd be so many people in the hospitals. Sales of alcohol are banned the judges are told to prepare for criminal hearings to run throughout the night congressmen tell their female staff stay out of the city because
不，不，不。为什么会这样？嗯……我的意思是，这是战略性的吗？这是沙文主义吗？不，这不是战略性的。这是沙文主义。是的。
there's going to be trouble there's going to be violence all this kind of thing the pentagon has got 19 000 troops but no dogs but no the concession. Because they have learned that... That doesn't look good. A couple of just small things before we approach the day. One, there are no women. It's a really, really interesting... So no Rosa Parks. So no Rosa Parks.
这是沙文主义。我的意思是，让我们直言不讳吧。民权运动的领导层是这样一代人，他们认为女性基本上会……正如我们在英国所说，她们会泡茶，但不是用蛋黄酱，完全正确，她们不会做三明治，但是的。所以有一个向“黑人女性自由战士”致敬的环节，正如她们所称的那样，但它是由一个男人发表的，而女性，罗莎·帕克斯等人被要求鞠躬，但她们不被允许说一个字。所以这本身就说明了问题。所以这随后开启了60年代将受到此巨大影响的运动之一，即女权主义。
No, no, no. And why is that? Well... I mean, is it strategic? Is it chauvinist? No, it's not strategic. It's chauvinist. Yeah.
完全正确。确实，还有同性恋权利。是的。我的意思是，女权主义的一部分来自于那些参与过60年代运动的人，他们说，我真的厌倦了泡茶。所以让我们回到那一天，1963年8月28日，非常热的一天。从清晨开始，很明显这将是一件大事。成千上万的人乘火车到达，每小时一百辆公共汽车穿过巴尔的摩港隧道。所以到10点左右，那个地方绝对挤满了人。很明显，人群比人们预期的要黑得多。
It's chauvinist. I mean, let's just be blunt about it. The civil rights movement's leadership are of a generation where they think the women will basically make the as we would say in britain they'll make the tea but not not with mayonnaise exactly they won't make the sandwiches but yeah so there is a tribute to negro women fighters for freedom as they are called but it is delivered by a man and the women so rosa parks and co are called upon to take a bow, but they're not allowed to say a single word. So that kind of tells its own story. And so that is then setting up one of the movements in the 60s that will be massively influenced by this, which is feminism.
所以他们以为，你知道，可能是50-50之类的。实际上，大约五分之一是白人，五分之四是黑人。出现的非裔美国人的数量让组织者感到惊讶。他们知道会很大，但他们不知道会这么大。孩子比他们预期的多得多，老年人也多得多。而且，从一开始就很明显，气氛不是……它更……它不完全是庆祝性的，那是错误的，但它是充满希望的，是的，它是热情的，它是自豪的，它不是暴力的，你知道，对很多人来说，它实际上
Exactly. And indeed, gay rights. Yeah. I mean, part of feminism comes out of people who've been involved in 60s movements who say, I'm actually sick of making the tea. So let's get to the day itself, 28th of august 1963 very hot day right from the early morning it's obvious this is going to be a massive deal so thousands and thousands of people arriving by train a hundred buses an hour coming through the baltimore harbour tunnel so by 10 o'clock or so the place is absolutely rammed it's obvious that the crowd is much blacker than people had anticipated.
是一个非常感人的、令人愉快的日子。所以鲍勃·迪伦为人群演唱，我不会享受那个，汤姆，因为我不喜欢鲍勃·迪伦。是的，是的，所有那些你被禁止做的模仿，但我认为我们可以允许你模仿鲍勃·迪伦。但琼·贝兹，她说她最深刻的记忆是看着人群，看到所有的教堂帽子。这可能对人们来说是一种神圣的体验，我的意思是人们像去教堂一样来了。但一些非常出人意料的人也在那里。查尔顿·赫斯顿在那里。那很出人意料，不是吗？那很出人意料。伯特·兰卡斯特，伯特·兰卡斯特伟大的自由派竞选，比利·怀尔德，西德尼·波蒂埃，马龙·白兰度，你的另一个受害者，汤姆。我们的制片人西奥正指着你说，不要做你的马龙·白兰度声音。我不会做的。
So they'd thought they would, you know, might be 50-50 or something. Actually, it's about a fifth white, four-fifths black. The number of African-Americans who turn up amazes the organizers. They knew it'd be big, but they didn't know it would be this big. There are far more children than they expected, far more older people. Also, right from the start it's obvious the mood is nothing it's much more it's not quite celebratory that's wrong but it is hopeful it's yes it's passionate it's proud it is it's not violent you know for a lot of people it's actually
所以他们原以为可能会是五五开之类的。实际上，大约五分之一是白人，五分之四是黑人。非裔美国人的到场人数让组织者感到震惊。他们知道规模会很大，但没想到会这么大。现场的孩子比他们预期的多得多，老年人也多得多。而且，从一开始就很明显，现场的气氛完全不是那种……怎么说呢，不是庆祝，那样说不对，但它是充满希望的，是的，它是热情的，它是自豪的，它不是暴力的，你知道，对很多人来说，这实际上是
a really moving well enjoyable day so bob dylan sings to the crowd i wouldn't enjoy that tom because i don't like bob dylan yeah yeah yeah all that you were banned from doing um impersonations but i think we can allow you bob dylan um but jane bears she said that the most striking memory she had was looking out at the crowds and seeing all the church hats it's there's a sacral experience perhaps for people i mean people have come as they would to church. But some very unexpected people are there. Charlton Heston was there. That's unexpected, isn't it? That's unexpected. Burt Lancaster, Burt Lancaster's great liberal campaign, Billy Wilder, Sidney Poitier, Marlon Brando, another of your victims, Tom. Our producer, Theo, is pointing at you saying, do not do your Marlon Brando voice. I'm not going to.
非常感人且令人愉快的一天。所以鲍勃·迪伦为人群演唱。汤姆，我可不会享受那个，因为我不喜欢鲍勃·迪伦。是啊是啊，你被禁止模仿，但我认为我们可以允许你模仿鲍勃·迪伦。嗯，简·贝尔斯说，她最深刻的记忆是看着人群，看到所有的教堂礼帽。这或许对人们来说是一种神圣的体验，我的意思是，人们就像去教堂一样来到这里。但现场还有一些非常出人意料的人。查尔顿·赫斯顿也在那里。这很出人意料，不是吗？确实出人意料。伯特·兰卡斯特，伯特·兰卡斯特伟大的自由主义运动，比利·怀尔德，西德尼·波蒂埃，马龙·白兰度，又是你的受害者之一，汤姆。我们的制片人西奥正指着你，说不要模仿马龙·白兰度的声音。我不会模仿的。
Josephine Baker? Marlon Brando's walking around carrying an electric cattle prod to symbolize police brutality. That's method acting. It is method acting taken to a ludicrous extreme, I agree with you. So, there are going to be 16 speakers and King is going to go last.
约瑟芬·贝克？马龙·白兰度拿着电击棒走来走去，象征着警察的暴行。这就是方法派表演。我同意你的看法，这是将方法派表演推向了荒谬的极端。所以，总共有16位演讲者，金博士将是最后一位。
There's been an argument about whether or not King should go last and the organizers said, well, listen, who wants to go after him? Because he is known as the best orator. Because he is already known by far as the best. So in a sense, it's the position of honour.
关于金博士是否应该压轴，一直存在争议，组织者说，好吧，听着，谁想在他之后发言呢？因为他被公认为最出色的演说家。因为他早已被公认为是最棒的。所以从某种意义上说，这是一个荣誉的位置。
You're the one who will be kind of last. But isn't there also a slight sense that that might be the graveyard slot? Because towards the end of the day, people start drifting away, get tired, a bit hot, mayonnaise is kicking in. You've had too much mayonnaise. Exactly.
你是那个会排在最后的人。但难道不也有一种轻微的感觉，觉得那可能是个“坟墓时段”吗？因为到了傍晚，人们开始散去，感到疲惫，天气有点热，蛋黄酱的劲儿上来了。你吃了太多的蛋黄酱。没错。
So, I mean, you and I here, we're here in June. I mean, I've been to Washington in August. It is unbelievably hot and humid and stifling. And even if you got
所以，我的意思是，你和我在这里，我们是在六月。我的意思是，我去过八月的华盛顿。那里热得难以置信，潮湿且令人窒息。即使你戴着
your church hat on, that sun is beating down. It is beating down. So one person dies of a heart attack. More than a thousand people are treated by the Red Cross. There's no violence at all.
教堂礼帽，那太阳也在暴晒。它在暴晒。所以有一个人死于心脏病发作。超过一千人接受了红十字会的治疗。根本没有任何暴力事件。
And I suppose also if people come in on the train, they've got to get the train back. They've got to get the train back. Exactly. And get the train back exactly and the speeches are fine but people heard them all before they're not that great and norman mailer he put it very well he said there was an air of subtle depression by the afternoon of wistful apathy which existed in many like a baseball game after it's obvious that one team is going to win basically so it's just a sort of sense you know you know how it. Like at a festival or anything,
我想如果人们是坐火车来的，他们还得坐火车回去。他们得坐火车回去。没错。坐火车回去，演讲很好，但人们之前都听过，也没那么精彩。诺曼·梅勒说得很好，他说下午时分有一种微妙的压抑感，一种忧郁的冷漠，就像一场棒球比赛，当一方明显要赢的时候，基本上就是那种感觉，你知道的。就像在节日或其他什么活动上，
you've been for the day out, it's the late afternoon, everyone's very hot, kind of time to go home, and number 16, Martin Luther King, steps up to the podium, and as he steps up, Tom,
你玩了一整天，已经是傍晚了，每个人都很热，差不多该回家了，第16位演讲者马丁·路德·金走上讲台，当他走上台时，汤姆，
there are people already leaving. There are people who've retreated from kind of where we are now, they've gone under the trees to escape the sun, there are people who are streaminged from kind of where we are now they've gone under the trees to escape the sun there are people who are streaming back towards the railway station and this is his moment his appointment with destiny and this of course is the perfect time for us to take a break okay so we will see you back in a few minutes for martin luther king's appointment with destiny. live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com that's therestisentertainment.com
已经有人在离开了。有些人从我们现在所在的地方撤退了，他们躲到树下避暑，有些人正涌向火车站，这是他的时刻，他与命运的约会，当然，现在是我们休息一下的绝佳时机，好的，几分钟后见，继续马丁·路德·金与命运的约会。现场门票请前往 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com
hello welcome back to the rest is history we are well we're having a dream aren't we dominic in the company of martin luther king who is um addressing the this great movement of of civil rights campaigners activists who've descended on washington in the summer of 1963 um they're all they're all a bit hot all a bit tired they've got to get back home so martin luther king is now stepping up he's got to grab their attention and he's got to grab the attention of america as well yeah because you know he he is being filmed correct this is going to be going out across the United States. Exactly right. So the networks have been covering the march off and on all day, but both ABC and NBC interrupt their regular programming
你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》，我们正在，嗯，我们正在做一个梦，不是吗，多米尼克？在马丁·路德·金的陪伴下，他正在向1963年夏天涌入华盛顿的伟大的民权运动活动家们发表讲话，嗯，他们都有点热，有点累，他们得赶回家，所以马丁·路德·金现在走上台，他必须抓住他们的注意力，他也必须抓住全美国的注意力。是的，因为你知道，他正在被拍摄，没错，这将传遍整个美国。完全正确。所以电视网整天都在断断续续地报道这次游行，但美国广播公司（ABC）和全国广播公司（NBC）都中断了常规节目，
to come to Martin Luther King at the platform. And he has been told by the other civil rights leaders, many of whom are quite jealous of him, they have told him, you have 10 minutes max. If you go over 10 minutes, and one of them says to him, Roy Wilkins says to him, you go over 10 minutes, we'll cut off your microphone. You know, don't mess around. So the pressure is on that. King, he is, as we said before, he's the third generation preacher. He was a brilliant speaker at kindergarten. He could recite bits of the Bible from memory.
转而直播马丁·路德·金在平台上的讲话。其他民权领袖——他们中许多人对他相当嫉妒——已经告诉他，你最多只有10分钟。如果你超过10分钟，其中一个人，罗伊·威尔金斯对他说，如果你超过10分钟，我们就切断你的麦克风。你知道，别搞砸了。所以压力很大。金，正如我们之前所说，他是第三代牧师。他在幼儿园时就是个出色的演说家。他能凭记忆背诵圣经片段。
And he's a, you know, I mean, he's a very, very learned theologian as well. Yeah. Very learned man. But he doesn't write his speeches all himself. He has people who help, because we said he gives 350 speeches a year. So he has two aides who help him with this,
而且他，你知道，我的意思是，他也是一位非常、非常有学问的神学家。是的。非常有学问的人。但他并不完全自己写演讲稿。他有助手帮忙，因为我们说过他一年要发表350次演讲。所以他有两位助手帮他处理这些，
Clarence Jones and Stanley Leveson. And they've been working on this speech for three to four days. Now, normally when he does his speeches, he has kind of interchangeable elements. So he does a bit of this, bit of that, like a preacher, like a vicar would, like a clergyman. Very used to speaking, you know, depending on the moments as the mood takes him. He will use this paragraph, that section, because they know this is the first time, really, that he is speaking not just to his base,
克拉伦斯·琼斯和斯坦利·莱维森。他们已经为这篇演讲准备了三到四天。通常情况下，当他发表演讲时，他有一些可互换的元素。所以他会做一点这个，做一点那个，就像牧师，像教区牧师一样，像神职人员一样。非常习惯于演讲，你知道，根据时刻和心情来定。他会使用这一段，那一部分，因为他们知道这是他第一次真正地不仅是对他的基本盘说话，
but to millions of Americans who will watch on TV who've probably never really heard him speak before. Yeah, exactly. So he can actually use riffs that he's used before. And the dream, the idea of having a dream is one of those riffs, right? Yeah. So they're in his hotel suite the night before, and they are actually debating, will he use that dream stuff?
而且是对数百万可能以前从未真正听过他演讲的美国人说话。是的，完全正确。所以他实际上可以使用他以前用过的即兴段落。而“梦想”，拥有一个梦想的想法就是其中之一，对吧？是的。所以前一天晚上他们在酒店套房里，他们实际上在争论，他会使用那些关于梦想的内容吗？
Because he has used it. He'd used it in a prayer service in georgia in 1962 he'd used it in north carolina at the end of 1962 he'd used it quite a lot the dream idiom throughout the summer of 1963 so he'd been at a fundraiser in chicago a week earlier and it said i'd have a dream that one day right down in birmingham alabama where the home of my friend was bombed last night, white men and Negro men, white women and Negro women will be able to walk together as brothers and sisters. And some people said to him, some of his aides actually said to him, I think that's a bit cliched. I think that stuff about the dream is a bit tiresome. So one wyatt t walker actually explicitly said to him do not use the lines i have a dream it's too trite right but i mean that's because presumably
因为他用过。他在1962年佐治亚州的一次祈祷仪式上用过，在1962年底在北卡罗来纳州用过，在1963年整个夏天他经常使用“梦想”这个习语。所以他一周前在芝加哥参加了一场筹款活动，他说：“我有一个梦想，有一天，在我的朋友昨晚被炸毁家园的阿拉巴马州伯明翰，白人男子和黑人男子，白人妇女和黑人妇女将能够像兄弟姐妹一样并肩行走。”有些人对他说，他的一些助手实际上对他说，我觉得那有点陈词滥调。我觉得关于梦想的东西有点令人厌烦。所以怀亚特·T·沃克实际上明确地对他说，不要使用“我有一个梦想”这些台词，太陈腐了，对吧？但我的意思是，那是因为大概
these guys have been in king's entourage all this time and so they've heard him do it loads and loads of times like me listening to your anecdotes well i mean it's like a band who have been playing in in clubs and pubs and you know above whatever, suddenly being given a stadium. And you're playing to millions of people who've never heard you before. So you want to go with your greatest hits. Right, this is what our producer, Tony, who's lurking in the background here, he says to us about the rest of you. I'm not comparing us with Martin Luther King, Tom.
这些家伙一直都在金的随从队伍里，所以他们听他讲过很多很多次了，就像我听你的轶事一样。嗯，我的意思是，这就像一个在俱乐部和酒吧里演出过的乐队，突然被给了一个体育场。而你正在为数百万从未听过你演出的人表演。所以你想用你的热门金曲。没错，这就是我们的制片人托尼，他正潜伏在背景里，他就是这么对我们说的。汤姆，我不是在拿我们和马丁·路德·金做比较。
That would be absolutely ridiculous. Just to be absolutely clear, I'm not comparing us. But yeah, you bring out the big guns. But actually, King stays up till four o'clock in the morning, the night before the big march. Well, he says, I am now going upstairs to my room to counsel with my Lord, i.e. Christ. And he's giving a political speech, but he's also giving a religious speech. But he decides, not going to use it.
那绝对是荒谬的。为了绝对清楚，我不是在比较我们。但确实，你会拿出杀手锏。但实际上，在大型游行的前一天晚上，金一直熬到凌晨四点。嗯，他说，我现在要上楼回房间去与我的主，也就是基督，商量。他是在发表政治演讲，但也是在发表宗教演讲。但他决定，不使用它。
They're right. It's tired. Or does he, though? I mean, that's what he says. Yeah, it is what he use it they're right it's too it's tired or does he though i mean that's what he says yeah it is what he says you're right there's a little bit of controversy about this isn't there fascinating you know we'll come to maybe how that i have a dream moment it's kind of kicks in it's fascinating because i have views on it it's fascinating for us who um you know we both do public speaking that this is a wonderful case of being able to go through a speech and to to see how the rhythm because he's of course he has a text but king is used to departing from his text let's go back to that moment he's introduced by philip randolph philip randolph is an enormous
他们是对的。这太陈旧了。或者他真的不用吗？我的意思是，这就是他说的。是的，这就是他说的。你是对的，关于这一点有一点争议，不是吗？太迷人了，你知道，我们稍后会谈到那个“我有一个梦想”的时刻是如何开始的，这很迷人，因为我有我的看法。对于我们这些，嗯，我们俩都做公开演讲的人来说，这是一个很好的案例，可以去通读一篇演讲稿，看看节奏，因为他当然有文本，但金习惯于脱稿。让我们回到那个时刻，他由菲利普·伦道夫介绍，菲利普·伦道夫是一个巨大的
man very torn and lanky king is about five foot six sort of short and stocky he stands there at the podium there's polite applause not rapturous applause and then he starts speaking and by the way his voice he has a tremendous voice yeah so he has this you've banned me from impersonating it i have banned you and i absolutely under no circumstances can you're allowed to but it is a tremendous it's this baritone yeah yeah rolling baritone and he starts the reference to the guy in whose shadow we're sitting. He says, five score years ago, a great American in whose symbolic shadow we stand today signed the Emancipation Proclamation.
人，非常瘦长，金大约五英尺六英寸，有点矮壮，他站在讲台上，有礼貌的掌声，不是狂热的掌声，然后他开始说话，顺便说一句，他的声音，他有一个惊人的声音。是的，所以他有这个，你禁止我模仿它，我禁止了你，而且在任何情况下你都绝对不能，但它是一个惊人的声音，这是男中音，是的，是的，浑厚的男中音，他开始提到那个我们正坐在其阴影下的人。他说，一百年前，一位伟大的美国人，我们今天站在他象征性的阴影下，签署了《解放黑人奴隶宣言》。
That's Abraham Lincoln. And right from the start, you see, he's anchoring this in American history, heritage, the great traditions of America. So Gary Young, whose book on the the speech i couldn't recommend more highly he points out that if you listen to an audiobook the audiobook is 150 words a minute if you give a slideshow presentation on zoom 100 words a minute but king is speaking at 77 words a minute so it's slow every word judged like a preacher in a pulpit tom which is what he is yeah that's exactly what he's doing and he has this device which he uses a lot anaphora yes you're familiar with a rhetorical yeah so the rhetorical device where you repeat
那是亚伯拉罕·林肯。从一开始，你看，他就把这锚定在美国的历史、遗产、美国的伟大传统中。所以加里·杨，我极力推荐他关于这篇演讲的书，他指出，如果你听有声读物，有声读物是每分钟150个单词，如果你在Zoom上做幻灯片演示，每分钟100个单词，但金的演讲速度是每分钟77个单词，所以很慢，每一个字都像讲坛上的牧师一样经过斟酌，汤姆，这正是他所做的。是的，这正是他所做的，他有一种他经常使用的修辞手法，排比，是的，你熟悉这种修辞，是的，就是那种你在连续句子的开头重复
the same phrase again and again at the beginning of successive sentences 100 years later the life of the negro is still sadly crippled by the manacles of segregation and the chains of discrimination 100 years later the negro lives on a lonely island of poverty in the midst of a vast ocean of material prosperity. 100 years later, again and again, reminding people Lincoln made this promise and it has not been fulfilled. But it's not just Lincoln, is it? It's the founding fathers.
同一个短语的修辞手法。一百年后，黑人的生活仍然悲惨地受到种族隔离枷锁和歧视锁链的束缚。一百年后，黑人生活在物质繁荣的汪洋大海中一个孤独的贫困岛屿上。一百年后，一次又一次，提醒人们林肯做出了这个承诺，但它还没有实现。但这不仅仅是林肯，不是吗？这是开国元勋们。
Right. You're absolutely right. It's the Constitution. This is really the point of issue between him and Malcolm X, because Malcolm X is saying black Americans should emancipate themselves from the entire structures of white America. King is saying, no, we are holding white America to its own promises, its own ideals, its own kind of best aspirations. Absolutely right. And this is an argument that reverberates to this
没错。你完全正确。这是《宪法》。这确实是他和马尔科姆·X之间争论的焦点，因为马尔科姆·X说美国黑人应该从整个白人美国的结构中解放自己。金说，不，我们是在要求白人美国兑现它自己的承诺，它自己的理想，它自己那种最好的愿望。完全正确。这是一个直到今天在黑人权利活动家之间仍然引起共鸣的争论，
day among campaigners for black rights some will say we're just asking that america live up to its own professed ideals and others will say america is poisoned from the start by the original sin of slavery yeah and king doesn't say the latter he explicitly says it's this wonderful metaphor the metaphor for which some actually some of his aides and some civil rights leaders say this speech ought to be remembered which is the metaphor of cashing a check he says in a sense we've come to our nation's capital to cash a check and he says when the architects of our republic wrote the declaration of independence in the constitution they were signing a promissory note that all men yes black
有些人会说我们只是要求美国实现它自己宣称的理想，而另一些人会说美国从一开始就被奴隶制的原罪所毒害。是的，金并没有说后者，他明确地说了，这是一个美妙的隐喻，一些他的助手和一些民权领袖说这篇演讲应该因为这个隐喻而被记住，那就是兑现支票的隐喻。他说，从某种意义上说，我们来到我们国家的首都兑现一张支票，他说，当我们的共和国建筑师写下《独立宣言》和《宪法》时，他们是在签署一张本票，保证所有的人，是的，黑人
men as well as white men you notice the emphasis on men which people wouldn't say today will be guaranteed the unalienable rights of life liberty and the pursuit of happiness and he says america has defaulted on this promise and we have come to cash it a check that will give us upon demand the riches of freedom and the security of justice and then there's a bit about the sort of urgency which you talked about so another anaphora now is the time to make real the promises of democracy now is the time to rise from the dark and desolate valley now is the time you know a very standard rhetorical technique the crowd like that all very good he's bringing in some biblical stuff so there's stuff about rolling waters you must be familiar with yeah just this
以及白人，你注意到对“人”的强调，人们今天不会这样说，都将被保障生命、自由和追求幸福的不可剥夺的权利。他说美国在这一承诺上违约了，我们来这里是为了兑现它，一张将根据要求给予我们自由的财富和正义的保障的支票。然后有一点关于你谈到的那种紧迫感，所以另一个排比，现在是实现民主承诺的时候了，现在是从黑暗和荒凉的山谷中崛起的时候了，现在是时候了，你知道，一种非常标准的修辞技巧，人群喜欢那样，非常好，他引入了一些圣经内容，所以有关于滚滚江水的内容，你一定很熟悉，是的，就是这个
rolling down like waters and righteousness like a mighty stream from uh the book of amos i'm not massively familiar with the book of amos that's tremendous brilliant yeah great book it's all great stuff so so now he's moving towards the end of the speech. And actually, this is how it's meant to end. So he's meant to end with these resounding words that one day will join hands and sing, free at last, free at last, thank God almighty, we are free at last. And had he ended then...
滚滚如水，正义如滔滔江水，来自阿摩司书，我对阿摩司书不是很熟悉，那太棒了，精彩，是的，伟大的书，都是伟大的内容。所以，现在他正走向演讲的结尾。实际上，这本该是结尾。所以他本该以这些响亮的话语结束：有一天我们将携手歌唱，终于自由了，终于自由了，感谢全能的上帝，我们终于自由了。如果他那时结束……
It wouldn't be remembered. It probably would not be remembered. It was fine. It was like standard Martin Luther King civil rights speech. It was absolutely fine. And then, I mean, there was a dispute about what happened. Some people say, like you just did, like you suggested earlier,
它就不会被记住。它可能不会被记住。这很好。这就像标准的马丁·路德·金民权演讲。这绝对很好。然后，我的意思是，关于发生了什么有一场争论。有些人说，就像你刚才做的那样，就像你之前建议的那样，
he was always actually going to use the dream stuff. He was just saying that because his aides were giving him a hard time about it. I'm not saying that. I mean, you know, he's a practiced orator. So he will have in his head riffs that he might be ready to use if he feels that the time is right
他其实一直打算使用那些关于梦想的内容。他只是那样说，因为他的助手们因为这件事让他很难堪。我不是那个意思。我的意思是，你知道，他是一位经验丰富的演说家。所以他脑子里会有即兴段落，如果他觉得时机成熟，他准备好使用它们。
but i think more than that he has a literal conviction that the spirit can descend and can animate him with pentecostal fire right he can speak with tongues and i think he literally believes this and i was kind of reading through the speech and then reading through this moment where it suddenly has a liftoff. And weirdly, I was reminded of a poem by the Welsh poet R.S. Thomas, which may seem a million miles away from the civil rights movement and everything. But R.S. Thomas is writing about a Methodist preacher. He's talking about this abandoned chapel that says that an amazing thing happened in this chapel. Here once on an evening like this in the darkness that was about his hearers, a preacher caught fire and burned steadily before them with a strange light, so that they saw the
但我认为不仅如此，他有一种字面上的信念，即圣灵可以降临并以五旬节的火焰激励他，对吧？他可以用方言说话，我想他确实相信这一点。我读着演讲稿，然后读到这一刻，它突然起飞了。奇怪的是，我想起了威尔士诗人R.S.托马斯的诗，这可能看起来离民权运动和一切相去甚远。但R.S.托马斯写的是一位卫理公会牧师。他谈到这个废弃的礼拜堂，说在这个礼拜堂里发生了一件神奇的事情。曾经在这样一个夜晚，在听众周围的黑暗中，一位牧师着了火，在他们面前稳稳地燃烧，带着一种奇异的光，以至于他们看到了
splendor of the barren mountains about them and sang their amens fiercely, narrow but saved in a way that men are not now. That's very good. And I think that that's kind of what happens he he catches fire yeah you know and and fire is the descent of the spirit in the christian tradition well it wouldn't be the rest is history unless i attempted to puncture enthusiasm with of course banal cynicism of course so there's a story that is often told that a gospel singer who was supposedly king's favorite gospel singer called mahalia jackson that she shouted up to him tell them about the dream martin tell them about the dream it's like a heckle yeah and which you would be used to by the way if you're a baptist preacher because people would often do that it'd be call
他们周围荒凉山脉的壮丽，并激烈地唱着阿门，狭隘但以一种人们现在没有的方式得救了。那非常好。我认为这就是发生的事情，他着火了，是的，你知道，火是基督教传统中圣灵的降临。好吧，如果不是《历史的余味》，我就不会试图用平庸的愤世嫉俗来破坏这种热情，当然。所以有一个经常被讲述的故事，一位福音歌手，据说是金最喜欢的福音歌手，名叫马哈莉亚·杰克逊，她对他大喊，告诉他们那个梦想，马丁，告诉他们那个梦想，这就像一个起哄，是的，如果你是浸信会牧师，你会习惯的，因为人们经常那样做，那是呼唤
and response and she shouts tell them about the dream and he starts improvising as he would have done and i'm sure you're right tom there are a lot of people in particularly in britain and europe who may be listening to this podcast, who are not religious, who will discount this aspect of King and his personality. But you're absolutely right. He is a committed believer. He would be the kind of person who would believe that he's seized by the Holy Spirit. Yeah, but I mean, if you want the Spirit to descend on you, you have to prepare. So he may have these kind of phrases ready in his head, waiting for the fire to catch. Right, which is what happens. I mean, he gets the sort of the heckle.
和回应，她大喊告诉他们那个梦想，他开始即兴发挥，就像他会做的那样。我相信你是对的，汤姆，在英国和欧洲有很多听这个播客的人，他们不是宗教信徒，他们会忽视金和他的个性的这一方面。但你完全正确。他是一位坚定的信徒。他会是那种相信自己被圣灵附体的人。是的，但我的意思是，如果你想让圣灵降临在你身上，你必须准备。所以他可能在脑子里准备好了这些短语，等待火点燃。没错，这就是发生的事情。我的意思是，他得到了那种起哄。
He's got very close to the end of his 10 minutes, by the way. So in the end, he ends up speaking for about 12 minutes or so. But he doesn't get cut off. But he doesn't get cut off. And you do get this sense that suddenly he catches fire. I mean, he would describe that he would fly off and then he'd be looking for a place to land. So this is him flying, taking off. he catches fire. I mean, he would describe that he would fly off and then he'd be looking for a place to land. So this is him flying, taking off.
顺便说一句，他已经非常接近他10分钟的结尾了。所以最后，他讲了大约12分钟左右。但他没有被切断。但他没有被切断。你确实感觉到他突然着火了。我的意思是，他会描述他会飞起来，然后他会寻找一个着陆的地方。所以这就是他飞翔，起飞。他着火了。我的意思是，他会描述他会飞起来，然后他会寻找一个着陆的地方。所以这就是他飞翔，起飞。
And then he gets going and he says, even though we face the difficulties of today and tomorrow, I still have a dream. It's a dream deeply rooted in the American dream. I think that's really important because that obviously, again, is that appeal to moderate white viewers who believe in the American dream. I have a dream that one day this nation will rise up and live out the true meaning of its creed we hold these
然后他开始说，尽管我们面临今天和明天的困难，我仍然有一个梦想。这是一个深深植根于美国梦的梦想。我认为这非常重要，因为这显然再次是对那些相信美国梦的温和派白人观众的呼吁。我有一个梦想，有一天这个国家会站起来，实现其信条的真正含义：我们认为这些
truths to be self-evident that all men are created equal and the crowd kind of cheers and then this and they're starting to get excited they cheer and then and then he's off and then there's this because the cheers presumably pep him up pep you up, of course. This is electricity now. He's firing. He's firing on all cylinders. I have a dream that one day on the Red Hills of Georgia, that's his home state, the sons of former slaves and the sons of former slave owners will be able to sit down together at the Temple of Brotherhood.
真理是不言而喻的，人人生而平等。人群开始欢呼，然后这个，他们开始兴奋起来，他们欢呼，然后，然后他开始了，然后有了这个，因为欢呼声大概让他振奋起来，振奋你，当然。这现在是电力。他正在开火。他火力全开。我有一个梦想，有一天在佐治亚州的红山上，那是他的家乡，前奴隶的儿子和前奴隶主的儿子将能够坐在兄弟情谊的圣殿里。
I have a dream that one day even the state of Mississippi, where he's just been, a state sweltering with the heat of injustice, sweltering with the heat of oppression, will be transformed into an oasis of freedom and justice. And then these very famous lines. I have a dream that my four little children will one day live in a nation where they will not be judged by the color of their skin, but by the content of their character. And then I have a dream today. And the audience, you can tell, they're really, really hooked at this point.
我有一个梦想，有一天连密西西比州，他刚去过的地方，一个被不公正的热浪煎熬、被压迫的热浪煎熬的州，将被改造成自由和正义的绿洲。然后是这些非常著名的台词。我有一个梦想，我的四个小孩子有一天会生活在一个国家，他们不会因为肤色而被评判，而是因为他们性格的内容。然后我今天有一个梦想。观众，你可以看出来，他们此时此刻真的被深深吸引了。
And he goes on and on, and then he gets to this point. I have a dream. Well, he has a direct biblical quote, isn't it, Tom? Yeah, from Isaiah. That's one day every valley shall be exalted, every hill and mountain shall be made low, the rough places made plain,
他继续讲下去，然后他到了这一点。我有一个梦想。好吧，他有一个直接的圣经引语，不是吗，汤姆？是的，来自以赛亚书。那是有一天每一个山谷都将被填满，每一座山岗都将被削平，崎岖的地方将变成平原，
the crooked places were made straight, and the glory of the lord shall be revealed and all flesh will see it incredibly powerful so what's that from that from isaiah the book of isaiah and the thing is that he is invoking their millennia worth of aspirations for justice and these are aspirations that are shared by white christians exactly so people listen to it who have been hitherto unmoved by the civil rights movement, there's nothing here that they could possibly object to. It's incredibly, you know, to us as white Britons reading this or watching the footage, I think it's still incredibly
弯曲的地方将变直，耶和华的荣耀将显现，凡有血气的必一同看见。令人难以置信的强大。所以那来自哪里？那来自以赛亚书，以赛亚书。问题是他正在援引他们数千年来对正义的渴望，这些渴望是白人基督徒所共有的，没错。所以听它的人，那些以前对民权运动无动于衷的人，这里没有什么他们可能反对的东西。这令人难以置信，你知道，对我们作为阅读这个或观看录像的白人英国人来说，我认为它仍然令人难以置信地
moving. It's so powerful. Sorry, there's a dog just there in the background. The amazing thing about it, as Gary Young points out in his book, is that this passage, the bit for which the speech is remembered, is just 301 words long. So it's less than a fifth of the total speech, and it lasts for two minutes and 40 seconds, which is a sixth of the whole. So it's remembered for this one passage. And then actually the end, I think the end is very moving. So then he goes back, back brilliantly he finds a way to end that incorporates both this stuff and the end that he had planned and he he takes it back to this idea of patriotism so he goes back to this song this hymn my country tis of thee sweet land of liberty of thee i sing which believe it or not tom the tune is god save the king
感人。它太强大了。抱歉，背景里有一只狗。正如加里·杨在他的书中所指出的，关于它令人惊奇的事情是，这段话，即这篇演讲被记住的部分，只有301个单词长。所以它不到总演讲的五分之一，持续时间为2分40秒，是整个演讲的六分之一。所以它因为这一段而被记住。然后实际上结尾，我认为结尾非常感人。所以他回到，回到精彩地，他找到了一种结尾方式，结合了这些内容和他计划的结尾，他把它带回到爱国主义这个想法上。所以他回到这首歌，这首赞美诗《我的国家，属于你》，甜蜜的自由之乡，我为你歌唱，信不信由你，汤姆，曲调是《天佑国王》。
wonderful very stirring for those of us brilliant he started singing that yeah very unexpected the speech could i mean this is the great takeaway from the rest this episode of the rest is history the speech would have been even better if it's sung but it's also got it's got the rhythms of all those kind of folk singers yeah Absolutely. And he ends with this geographical tour of the Union. Let freedom ring from the prodigious hilltops of New Hampshire. Let freedom ring
美妙，非常激动人心，对于我们这些，精彩，他开始唱那个，是的，非常出人意料。演讲可以，我的意思是，这是《历史的余味》这一集的最大收获，如果唱出来，演讲会更好，但它也有，它有所有那些民谣歌手的节奏，是的，绝对。他以这次对联邦的地理巡回结束。让自由从新罕布什尔州巨大的山顶响起。让自由响起
from the mighty mountains of New York. Let freedom ring from the heightening Alleghenies of Pennsylvania. So he's gone through the North and then he goes South. But not only that,
从纽约雄伟的山脉。让自由从宾夕法尼亚州不断升高的阿勒格尼山脉响起。所以他走过了北方，然后他去了南方。但不仅如此，
let freedom ring from Stone Mountain of Georgia. Let freedom ring from Lookout Mountain of Tennessee. Let freedom ring from every hill of Georgia, let freedom ring from Lookout Mountain of Tennessee, let freedom ring from every hill and molehill of Mississippi, from every mountainside, let freedom ring. And then he goes on and he comes back to the point
让自由从佐治亚州的石山响起。让自由从田纳西州的瞭望山响起。让自由从佐治亚州的每一座山丘响起，让自由从田纳西州的瞭望山响起，让自由从密西西比州的每一座山丘和小土丘响起，从每一座山坡，让自由响起。然后他继续讲，他回到
where he was always planning to end, with the day when all of God's children, black men and white men, Jews and Gentiles, Protestants and Catholic, will be able to join hands and sing in the words of the old Negro spiritual, free at last, free at last, thank God almighty. We're free at last. It's actually really stirring.
他一直计划结束的地方，那一天，上帝所有的孩子，黑人男子和白人男子，犹太人和外邦人，新教徒和天主教徒，将能够携手歌唱古老的黑人灵歌中的歌词，终于自由了，终于自由了，感谢全能的上帝。我们终于自由了。这实际上真的很激动人心。
Yeah, I mean, just hearing you do it sends shivers down the spine. I mean, not... Chilling shivers, Tom. No, I feel an urge to go out there and fight for freedom. Well, Jonathan Kennedy, who was watching it, who had never seen a full, or heard a full Martin Luther King speech, apparently watched it in the Oval Office on TV and he said
是的，我的意思是，仅仅听你做一遍就让人脊背发凉。我的意思是，不是……令人不寒而栗的寒颤，汤姆。不，我有一种冲动想出去为自由而战。好吧，乔纳森·肯尼迪，他在看，他从未看过完整或听过完整的马丁·路德·金演讲，显然他在椭圆形办公室的电视上看了，他说
to his aides, he is good. Yeah, and Kennedy would know because Kennedy's a great orator too. He is damn good. Interestingly, I mean, the fascinating thing is that after that, and we've said how moving it is, did it convert anybody? And the brutal answer is no, it didn't actually. I accept that.
对他的助手说，他很棒。是的，肯尼迪会知道，因为肯尼迪也是一位伟大的演说家。他真的很棒。有趣的是，我的意思是，迷人的事情是，在那之后，我们已经说过它有多感人，它改变了任何人吗？残酷的答案是，没有，它实际上没有。我接受这一点。
But I think that it does contribute to what will become the vibe of the 60s. It does, of course. All you need is love, all that kind of thing. It does, of course, but not initially. No, but it's a slow burner. It's a slow burner. So at the time, do you want to know what the Jackson, Mississippi clarion ledger said? The next day, the front page was a
但我认为它确实促成了后来成为60年代氛围的东西。它确实，当然。你所需要的只是爱，所有那种东西。它确实，当然，但不是最初。不，但它是一个慢热的。它是一个慢热的。所以当时，你想知道密西西比州杰克逊市的《号角纪事报》说了什么吗？第二天，头版是一张
photograph of the litter left in washington and the headline was washington is clean again with negro trash removed so that i mean there's a stunning shocking thing to read of course gives you a sense of polarization i think that that sense of, well, all you need is love, is something that palpably reverberates through the 60s. It does, but among people who already agree with it, Tom, I think, to some degree. Of course, but often these are people who are young. And so the youth spirit of the 60s, I'm sure, you know, because it's the intersection point between what is quite a conservative tradition, the biblical tradition of the black southern churches, and the kind and the youth quake of the 60s counterculture. And Martin Luther King's career obviously will continue throughout the 60s until his assassination in
华盛顿留下的垃圾的照片，标题是“华盛顿干净了，黑人垃圾被清除了”。所以，我的意思是，这是一件令人震惊、令人震惊的事情，当然让你感觉到两极分化。我认为那种“你所需要的只是爱”的感觉，是60年代明显引起共鸣的东西。它确实，但汤姆，我认为在某种程度上，是在那些已经同意它的人中间。当然，但这些人通常很年轻。所以60年代的青年精神，我肯定，你知道，因为它是相当保守的传统——南方黑人教会的圣经传统——与60年代反文化的青年震荡之间的交汇点。马丁·路德·金的职业生涯显然将在整个60年代持续，直到他在
1968. And when he gets killed, he's seen as being a martyr not just for his Christian beliefs, but for the spirit of 60s progressivism as well, don't you think? I do think that, Tom, but I think you of 60s progressivism as well. Don't you think? I do think that, Tom. But I think you've jumped very quickly from 1963 to 1968. Well, that's because we're running out of time, Tom. Well, that is because we're running out of time. But it's our podcast, Tom. We can do what we like.
1968年被暗杀。当他被杀时，他被视为不仅为他的基督教信仰，而且为60年代进步主义的精神而殉道，你不觉得吗？我确实那样认为，汤姆，但我认为你
But I think what that slightly misses is that the fact that the impact of the speech at the time wanes very quickly. I understand that. So it's barely discussed in 1964. Well, there is this question about, would the speech be remembered were it not for the assassination? Absolutely. Because by 1966, King is saying in speeches,
对60年代进步主义的精神。你不觉得吗？我确实那样认为，汤姆。但我认为你从1963年跳到1968年太快了。好吧，那是因为我们时间不多了，汤姆。好吧，那是因为我们时间不多了。但这是我们的播客，汤姆。我们可以做我们想做的。
well, actually, I'll tell you what happens in 1966. He gives a speech in Chicago and he is booed by young black men. He's yesterday's man. The action is with the more radical. So the Black Panthers are on the scene now. And afterwards, he says, I had preached to them about my dream, but they were hostile,
但我认为这稍微错过了一点，即演讲在当时的影响力很快就减弱了。我明白这一点。所以它在1964年几乎没有被讨论。好吧，有一个问题是，如果没有那次暗杀，这篇演讲会被记住吗？绝对不会。因为到1966年，金在演讲中说，
watching the dream that they had so readily accepted turn into a frustrating nightmare. In other words, they're sick of hearing about the dream. They're sick of hearing all this when their hopes are constantly being frustrated. And actually, by the time he dies in 1968, he himself has become much more radical.
好吧，实际上，我告诉你1966年发生了什么。他在芝加哥发表演讲，被年轻的黑人男子嘘。他是昨日黄花。行动在于更激进的人。所以黑豹党现在出现在现场。事后，他说，我曾向他们传道关于我的梦想，但他们充满敌意，
He's speaking about economic justice, about basically socialism. And he's speaking out against Vietnam, isn't he? and he's speaking out against vietnam and he's speaking out against against vietnam and some people so some of his aides and his friends say he shouldn't actually be remembered for the i have a dream speech he should be remembered for his later more radical speeches attacking the war in vietnam attacking imperialism and capitalism and that that is truer to the man he became because one of the paradoxes of this is that even though that i i have a dream speech is absolutely part of the kind of the
看着他们如此轻易接受的梦想变成了令人沮丧的噩梦。换句话说，他们厌倦了听到关于梦想的事情。当他们的希望不断受挫时，他们厌倦了听到这一切。实际上，到他1968年去世时，他自己已经变得激进得多了。
kaleidoscope of 60s radicalism it's kind of part of the mood music in the long run it does seem that it is an expression of the civil rights movement that is most congenial to conservatives agreed so yeah you know that's why basically the Martin Luther King who's being celebrated at the Lincoln Memorial and at his feet is the Martin Luther King who gives the I have a dream speech, not the Martin Luther King who is making speeches against Vietnam. Yeah, absolutely. Tom, I couldn't agree with you more. And that's what a lot of King scholars say, that actually Martin Luther King and the emphasis
他在谈论经济正义，基本上是社会主义。他在公开反对越南，不是吗？他在公开反对越南，他在公开反对越南。有些人，所以他的一些助手和朋友说，他不应该因为“我有一个梦想”演讲而被记住，他应该因为他后来更激进的演讲而被记住，攻击越南战争，攻击帝国主义和资本主义，那对他成为的那个人更真实。因为这其中的悖论之一是，即使“我有一个梦想”演讲绝对是60年代激进主义万花筒的一部分，它是长期氛围音乐的一部分，但它似乎确实是民权运动中最符合保守派口味的表达。同意，所以是的，你知道，这就是为什么基本上在林肯纪念堂和他的脚下被庆祝的马丁·路德·金是发表“我有一个梦想”演讲的马丁·路德·金，而不是发表反对越南演讲的马丁·路德·金。是的，绝对。汤姆，我完全同意你的看法。这就是许多金学者所说的，实际上马丁·路德·金和对
on this particular speech, it's a kind of way of sanitizing him and making him less nuanced, more moderate, less unsettling, less confrontational of a figure. And that actually, if you were being really harsh, now we've talked about how moving the speech is. If you were being really harsh, and I'm not saying I would necessarily take this line, you would say this is the rhetorical equivalent of John Lennon's Imagine.
这篇特定演讲的强调，这是一种净化他、使他不那么细微、更温和、更不令人不安、更不具对抗性的方式。实际上，如果你真的非常苛刻，现在我们已经谈到了这篇演讲有多感人。如果你真的非常苛刻，我不是说我一定会采取这种立场，你会说这是约翰·列侬的《想象》的修辞等价物。
You said about the spirit of the 60s, Tom, that it is kind of let's all be friends, join hands. But I mean, my repost to that would be, I know you hate John Lennon, I know you hate Imagine, but Imagine is an incredibly popular song that has created a kind of mood music for millions of people. And I don't think that that's necessarily an insult no well i like martin luther king i think the i have a dream speech is tremendously powerful i wouldn't compare it with imagine because as you rightly say i absolutely despise imagine with every fiber of my being but um why this is remembered is because i think the american dream is obviously very powerful the life liberty and the pursuit of happiness the rights and stuff and i think the speech captures this sense that the dream has not been fulfilled but it's still you know it doesn't
你谈到了60年代的精神，汤姆，即它是那种“让我们都成为朋友，携手共进”。但我的反驳是，我知道你讨厌约翰·列侬，我知道你讨厌《想象》，但《想象》是一首极其流行的歌曲，为数百万人创造了一种氛围音乐。我不认为那一定是一种侮辱。不，好吧，我喜欢马丁·路德·金，我认为“我有一个梦想”演讲非常强大。我不会把它和《想象》相比，因为正如你正确所说，我绝对鄙视《想象》，用我全身的每一个纤维，但是，嗯，为什么这被记住是因为我认为美国梦显然非常强大，生命、自由和追求幸福，权利等等，我认为演讲捕捉到了这种梦想尚未实现的感觉，但它仍然，你知道，它不
do to be unduly cynical about it that there is a promise there as an outside someone who's not american i think that a dream in which people of all races and backgrounds can live harmoniously is much better than one in which it's taken for granted that injustice is so kind of shot through the fabric of american history and its constitution that there's no you know there's no solution yeah i agree with you that to me is its power that it's not so it's not cynical it's not it's optimistic it's optimistic offers hope the optimism the hope and of course the religious side of it is what gives it the texture, isn't it? The biblical quotations, the rolling cadences
应该对它过于愤世嫉俗，那里有一个承诺。作为一个局外人，一个不是美国人的人，我认为一个所有种族和背景的人都能和谐相处的梦想，比一个理所当然地认为不公正已经渗透到美国历史及其宪法的结构中，以至于没有，你知道，没有解决方案的梦想要好得多。是的，我同意你的看法，对我来说，这就是它的力量，它不是，它不是愤世嫉俗的，它是乐观的，它是乐观的，提供希望。乐观，希望，当然，它的宗教方面是赋予它质感的东西，不是吗？圣经引语，滚滚的节奏
and so on and so forth. Tom, we've talked long enough. So King, it took him, what, 12 minutes to deliver this beautiful piece of oratory. We've spoken for far longer and come up with nothing remotely comparable. Well, that's what critics are all about, isn't it? Talking at enormous length about something
等等等等。汤姆，我们谈得够久了。所以金，他花了，什么，12分钟来发表这篇美丽的演说。我们讲了更久，却想不出任何类似的东西。好吧，这就是评论家所做的一切，不是吗？谈论某件事
that is delivered in much punchier form. That they can't possibly hope to reproduce. But it's also a reflection of the fascination of the broad theme of the civil rights movement and how it impacts, not just on America, but on the West more broadly. But also the fascination of Martin Luther King as a character.
以更简洁的形式交付。他们不可能希望复制。但这也是对民权运动这一广泛主题的迷恋的反映，以及它如何影响，不仅是美国，而且是更广泛的西方。但也对马丁·路德·金作为一个角色的迷恋。
And so we've focused very much on one speech but I do think we should come back and do some episodes on his life and his career and on the civil rights movement and other aspects of it we'll undoubtedly come back to this well on that bombshell Tom
所以我们非常关注一篇演讲，但我确实认为我们应该回来做一些关于他的生活和职业生涯，以及民权运动和其他方面的剧集。我们无疑会回到这一点。好吧，在那颗重磅炸弹上，汤姆，
I think we should stroll off down to look at some more memorials more monuments it's an amazing place, Washington DC steeped in history and we're going to go off and have a look around. If the Washington Tourist Board are listening,
我认为我们应该漫步去看看更多的纪念馆，更多的纪念碑。这是一个神奇的地方，华盛顿特区，沉浸在历史中，我们要去四处看看。如果华盛顿旅游局在听，
we do take donations. Yeah, we are available for hire. And on that... Commercial. On this utterly inappropriate and incongruous note, which is absolutely what you expect from the rest is history.
我们确实接受捐款。是的，我们可以受雇。在那……商业广告。在这个绝对不合适和不协调的音符上，这绝对是你对《历史的余味》的期望。
Goodbye, and we'll see you next time. Goodbye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
再见，我们下次见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。